here we see the markiplier stranded
alone on an island
only as which state is survivals here we
will chronicle his slow descent into
madness although it's not that slow sure
your mouth hey what do you think you're
doing over there you better get off my
Beach
stay away from my whale carcass I called
that shut the hell up he's made a tiny
little home on the beach or is in the
process of building it will it help him
will it aid him probably not
hi Barney you get the hell off my camp
that's right you get out of here this is
my Beach what do you think No No
Oh your friend bastards your way from a
in a way from a goddamn Beach don't be a
poop on it
are you dead but not be pooping you
better be dead yeah goddamned Birds get
off like that's right yeah what I tell
God get off my house it's my beach house
I claimed it get off your damn pigeon
crap
seagulls huh can I eat you please tell
me I can eat you and I just I didn't
just commit huh there's so many of you
why are there so many of you thank you
huh you deserved it I didn't deserve to
you deserve it yes deaf death is an
acceptable alternative to you living huh
I'm gonna destroy my shelter but first
I'm gonna take you bastards down with me
get off my shelter
what do you excuse me sir this is a no
turtle zone I don't know who you think
you are
don't make me oh don't make me he was
coming right for me Oh God he charged
oh he's gonna kill me Oh doh
the first blow to his sanity kills his
only friend the only one who wanted to
show him love well apparently I'm the
beach bum Massacre issed
cuz I keep murdering and yet they keep
coming
cry for the dead corpses of their
friends bye everybody have fun in hell
hmm hello dead man you are very naked
are you Bruce Willis from castaway
where's your Wilfred why do I not have a
head am I completely headless because
it's very weird I'm looking at my shadow
right now
oh no I am the monster well in the
cannibal who what is this sharp stick my
favorite a rag even better a bottle
empty the best prepare to die turtle
Hulk Hulk Hulk time to go wash off the
gallons of blood okay bye sploosh moose
am i washing it off yet have I washed
have I wished I can't tell from walking
her I'm swimming it's that weird low OH
you die die die die yeah yeah I got you
you don't look so good ah you shouldn't
come so close I get 1 1 huh I bet you
don't like this you're about to impale
your friends oh you're being used to
murder your family isn't this diabolical
what you like it yeah weirdo the
markiplier has found a steady supply of
food with this food and this shelter
there's no way he could possibly screw
up his survival can't carry him on a
trough fish ordered it all go you damn
Birds who you the hell out here this is
my Beach stay away from my Beach I
warned you I also warned you and I
warned you the warning is death in case
you didn't know goodbye bye goodbye
do I try yeah the beach murder ass kiss
kiss murder ass masochist murderer
masochist huh where'd you come from
hey I'm the beaten beach murder oh you
do not have a sharp stick you better not
don't even think about it yeah you
destroy to hear ah yeah I'm pretty
dangerous didn't you see me kill all
those birds I was a warning to the birds
but also to yay
how can I maintain my savagery if
there's birds right y'all yeah you move
on I'm gonna be able to campfire no I'm
not gonna build that one build burn I'll
be doing nothing
yeah that's right build that right there
let me get my mom what are you doing
what are you doing lady I don't have our
man no but you look like you might be an
ample substitute don't think I can't
take it
hi hi Amanda what are you out no dad
what am i doing why am i hugging the
ground why am i poking the markiplier is
bad at making friends so I'm dead good
for me oh good I'm in the cave of
nightmares cool at least there's a lot
of supplies down here well looks like
I'll be sitting pretty for a while are
your noises in the darkness I see you I
don't know what the hell that was all
about but I see you so I gotta fight my
way out here huh
bet if I die in here ain't no coming
back huh I gotta get out of here ah
lucky girl just be this okay yes he'll
only serve to further slip him into
insanity oh come on
no you [ __ ] ass
well how's that uh okay son would you
believe me if I told you we're all gonna
crash and die that's craziness dad well
it's just a feeling
oh there's something on the wing oh no
son I was right I told you so I was
right
ah oh that's a good hold of nothingness
I like that so you an adventurer down
there ah why did I die who's going into
a hole no I'm not dead I don't believe
it I don't believe it for a second I'm
alive god damn it I'm dead okay so this
is a lot of dead bodies I like it good
good
oh I didn't even notice that this place
was lined with fingers must be finger
foods huh hello Fran could you be more
naked and pick up my dead and dying son
and carry him off into the woods for
unknown reasons thank you
hello lady have you seen my friend our
Amanda she uh I lost her and if you
could just point me in the right around
her fixation the eagle I'm the prettiest
butterflies ball
I can't possibly fall and die from this
strange a swim fly in the middle of the
lake that's good that's right I miss I
don't know I don't know what's happening
my survival skills are not good enough
for this game okay thank you thank you
magical like a flight I'll be on my way
to the beach now so I could be king
Beach murder masochist by oh good I
found the island of graphical bugs my
favorite aah
don't let me go Oh God I'm all climbing
I'm all hacking I'm climbing climbing on
top of Ironforge
hello my little starfish friend have you
noticed some strange things happening
from the headless man who goes on a
massacre and kills all life on the beach
no okay weird set me up no no my
headless corpse I was so close to life
yo Fox the markiplier also has a very
bad habit of not hitting the record
button when he needs to and he ends up
babbling like a madman to nothingness
for hours on end wasting time wasting
precious moments and overall being a
giant [ __ ] [ __ ] in the best way
how you birds you stay out of here just
down the Red Birds Eye man it's gonna
slap you under the sky yeah I just built
all this with my bare hands and our
mandus bare hand that sounds like you
get off of life
this isn't or matter has something to
say to you where's what's wrong what's
wrong guy you look shy don't be Amanda
loves you
I've never loved everyone especially you
out there in the audience
hey hey say of my effigy hey hey say out
there is a respectful place of dead
bodies you stay away from me
what was that did I hear something in
the woods there what's something calling
me into the woods what's hot you need me
to go into the woods Thank You lightning
God the birds murder mattress will go
heed your call they will avoid me with
my human effigy they're not really human
anymore get out of here
get out of her Amanda whoa what's this
hello friend have you met our manda your
do it get along we don't get too close
she's mine something tells me you're not
quite as fun as our Amanda I don't know
the utility of you when you're kind of
grossing me out with your old lady nails
there I'm just gonna go running through
the woods for a little bit um does
everyone like my combo aksar manda thing
here huh this is a pretty effective
weapon if you ask me they're never gonna
know what hit him
those cannibals don't have the mind of
markiplier on their side they're
practically doomed screwed the foots
the dead basically didn't hello you were
in the intro sequence what are you doing
here
you look lovely but why then a boat
don't tell me there's a boat here can I
get off oh my god it's a boat that'll
let it boat to me on our man to finally
sail away in our vacation you and I are
gonna have a lovely time oh we're gonna
have the most fantastical wedding oh did
I say wedding hold out don't get excited
arm and I let it slip but I just slipped
a ring on your finger when you weren't
looking let us away look Amanda it's the
most beautiful
okay everyone seems to be dead on here
but that's okay isn't it beautiful
Amanda oh it's so lovely oh but jeez our
man I was about to do the outro you just
killed a bird god damn it stop gotta
stop killing your birds are manda you're
going crazy all right so anyway everyone
I hope you're enjoying my adventures on
the island alone I call this markiplier
island so if you are and you don't think
I'm crazy
please leave a like down below maybe if
you do think I'm crazy
thank you storm gods I've never got
wonderful time here so if you are too
please check out the other videos that
I've done and thank you again for
watching and as always I'm gonna see you
in the next video bye bye birds
too bad you will be missed
person is suggested assuming sorry your
name